how are you writing in some of the
subtext so much of the movie there are
things implied nothing's really said but
the audience gets a general feeling they
know how these characters either feel
about each other or where things are
going
how are you writing that in well um
subtext generated in probably two ways
one is if this topic of your scene is
why are you cheating on me as it
sometimes is say with harsh and Carol
you have them talk about anything but
that in a way and in a context so harsh
and Carol talking about their marriage
whilst to res is in the other room and
overhearing things you do it in that way
you you go off point of a conversation
you have a conversation about how
difficult it is to repair the damn
plumbing or whatever but and you do that
in order to make your point very clear
which is damn it this is this is wrong
all of this is wrong and the other way
which is really a one of my favorite
ways is to just describe behavior in a
certain context so Carolyn Torres riding
in a car what is she looking at what is
she doing what is this what's what's
actually going on and none of it has
anything to do with oh I don't know
camera angles or anything like that it's
just about what's happening which is the
basis of all drama whether it's a
screenplay or or play how people inhabit
a space at a certain time that's it it
seems almost laughably simple or easy
but it rarely makes it intact to a
screen in the way that that this has
enhanced greatly by the Muse on sin and
and and the performances and everybody
in every department just working to
preserve a fundamental truth about a
piece of material
you